doch du setzt yamaha
jo leute herzlich willkommen zu einer
runde minecraft partie
ich zog meine party mit level cache
größte ich jetzt geht's auch schon los
hier
minecraft party und so beste
wahrscheinlich schon beste spielmodus
schön dass ich in der wand malte wie man
da driftet was es geht schon direkt los
mit federer dran oder so ich bin direkt
runter ich bin direkt runter gefallen
er wisse dass das nicht in dieses spiel
super gelte es wirklich so dass bob ein
bisschen diese dieses vereines bisschen
tricky ich fange die ganze durch kinder
und hält auch also hat aus der kurve
alter alte alter also sobald ich
losfahre fall ich direkt runter ja alte
du musst halt wirklich langsam fahren
alle 23 sekunden noch mal nach vorne
weil ich sonst dick aus der kurve
fliegen ja ich hab die kurve mich ich
bin ihr letzter klar ob ich ein bisschen
mies es ist echt mies dass pferde
driften in der kurve 28 davon weiß ich
von vielen auf jeden fall hier meine
erste folge übrigens minecraft party
kennen sie wahrscheinlich schon von
anderen youtube das spiel ist ziemlich
lustig man darf nicht bringen
und man muss immer hier seine linie
ziehen nein ach das war dieser ja das
ist richtig schwierig
man steht hier instant wie ärgerlich das
war vergisst du das geht auch richtig
mehr vorbei ich lebe noch players
letzten 11 okay ich hab jetzt alle man
okay aber wir sind schon relativ hoch
platziert wir sind irgendwie 50 sechster
ja geil das läuft ja ehrlich gesagt eher
bei mir auch ein bisschen
aber ein spielmodus habe ich da das ist
der beste da bester gewonnen der
vorletzte job macht ist mir zum
verhängnis geworden
sonst wäre ich immer unter den ersten
fünf zumindest wahlalter ich lerne so
der hölle
ich habe hier meine special taktik
immerhin immer diagonale springen passt
auch irgendwie so eine taktik beim
aufreißen
ich habe einfach nur die pfeiler taktik
was geht ab mit mir was ist los
scheiße übrigen spiele ich heute mit dem
sgv zog es wirklich ist richtig tja was
geht arbeiter
es kam auf youtube es gibt sagt habe ich
ist man in der youtube als der link den
nutzer links 1000 meinen tube nutzer
namens exakt und mein schöner name ist
das richtig strange das tor freuen weil
ich kriege immer vor augen schmerzen
durch die ganzen fahrten ok und alter
wir rüber kommen
mein gott oh mein gott jetzt müssen wir
das schaffen haben jetzt nicht mal
fällen ja es ist wahr fällen um ein grad
der vorletzte jump ich habe euch gesagt
der vorletzte topfitten immer zum
verhängnis oh mein gott immer der
vorletzte chance
okay man muss dazu sagen dass jared
ziemlicher job man pro ist ja aber der
volle zugang sechster platz okay
es würde ist der platz ja ja ja ja ja ja
okay bei dem spielmodus habe ich letztes
mal gewonnen habe ich den ersten platz
okay in dem in dem spielmodus muss ich
sagen hier ist reinstes glück
ja
im moment schon oma ist eigentlich nicht
gerade jetzt kommt wieder ein bisschen
oder wenn es geht dann geht's wenn's
geht neid oder fast nie nach man darf
man diese -50% juni eigentlich töten ich
könnte die ganze zeit macht es nicht der
kinderzug also deswegen lag nicht so
harte hunde und halter der hunde server
kommt schon schwierig würde ein
zwanzigstel schleife 15
das war jetzt auch keine glanzvolle
runde ich hab halt keine kurse
okay was ist das noch mal ach ja hier
das auch ziemlich cool ist auch ziemlich
coole muss hier halt über der fläche am
nächsten überleben und dann werden die
auf einmal raus und so die plattform ist
die center rating deshalb ziemlich sind
sylvester angebrachter spiel dabei den
ganzen hof
diese krise kollege lebst du noch oder
lebst du noch eher ich leb noch hey mein
gott nicht auf die roten nicht auf die
roten
ich freue mich auf die roten abgaben auf
die drauf wird er natürlich die karten
sofort ab wenn du länger als die sekunde
drauf bleibt stürmisch
nein ich lege ich lege ich denke nein
nein bitte lass mich überleben das über
die mauern ein
ich habe unglücklich vor ausgepackt auch
aus nein nein ich mein leben als erster
das ist ziemlich cool wenn ich das nicht
das neue in meinem rücken um shambala
das alles aber auch barkeeper weise
verstehen geblieben als es stoppt hieß
und trotzdem zurück porto
das kann manchmal sein kommt ein
bisschen schlau und nein natürlich das
ist so verbuggt alter ich habe halt
wirklich gestanden schauen ja ich war
bislang auch schon war ich auch schon
also habe ich schon gestanden und wenn
einfach zurückgebracht zur hölle
ich will einfach zurückgebracht was zur
hölle oh gott oh gott na ja lexikon 20
21 das ist auch richtig dass dieses auch
meister das ist theater das stück i da
muss man ein bisschen glück haben
ich habe keine ahnung ausreichen soll
ganz ehrlich ihr stern steht man in
sekunden lang sechs players noch alter
sechs players war bin ich vielleicht
drei player ist okay ich bin vierter
sogar ich glaube ich bin vierter was ja
ja das sei
patrick i und es gibt halt doch sehr
sehr schnell
man kann eben auch nicht irgendwie
auswahl muss halt immer nur wegrennen
man kann nicht drunter oder drüber
auch gingen voll richtig richtig richtig
richtig theater aber sie die drei leben
hier nur ja diesen gut alter die ok
jetzt einen effekt hat ein viertel des
verbrauchs fertig bin schäfer sogar
vielleicht nicht schlecht läuft bei dir
alter läuft bei dir
okay ich habe einen ersten platz geholt
mehr will ich gar nicht fix the world
okay ich habe noch keinen ersten geholt
das nicht so schön war das noch mal ach
ja hier mit dem snowboard direkt
abgebaut
oh mein gott wenn man wenn man vom
schneeball getroffen das mal raus direkt
instant okay ich bin tot
das war richtig jetzt habe ich zwei
eliminiert alter mich ab gehe nicht
lange nicht lange bitten so ärgerlich
alter immer wenn man im lag eliminiert
wird gibt es ist mein spielmodus alter
weißt du was bei rage mode aufkomme hd
nebenzimmer den schneeball fliegen und
mit denen die leute erwischt ja sie
fliegen ein bisschen komisch
die fliegen schon das land
übrigens ist unsere erste aufgabe heute
zusammen und vielen freunden wir haben
uns bei diesem gefällten ist weiterhin
kennengelernt
das jahr als auch sehr schlecht gibt ja
die leute die auf man channel sind
ich packe jerry's channel in die
beschreibung schaut mal vorbei
in form der mann soll sie sein gebt euch
das mal
und ja wir machen jetzt weiter hier ein
das diesen spielen wieder dieses aber
das mag ich bin zumindest am anfang
unter gefallen und jetzt aus es geht
jetzt so wie sein körper ehrlich gesagt
kann die spring nein natürlich nicht
auch sah habe ich dir doch gesagt ich
bin so geistig versucht sich bringen
halte ich denke ja klar ich kann auf den
graben zu laufen nicht halt ich bin ich
bin fünfter oder sechster wieder ich bin
immer ziemlich hoch platziert aber erst
das 26 26 23
der trick ist halt einfach man muss
diese dinger verstehen die spiele und
das der spielmodus ist geil
ok dieses mini jump'n'run okay es liebig
man das ist ein bisschen magie aber ein
bisschen aber wir müssen mal gucken was
machen
ich bin ich mal ziemlich schlecht aber
mal schauen wie wir das meistern
ich war ja ich bin ganz auf die
druckplatte getreten und wurde trotzdem
zurückgebracht das war ein bisschen
komisch login neunter scheiß drauf als
neunter geht eigentlich auf meine mutter
wird nicht anders geht jetzt nicht okay
jetzt leiterin
ok es auch angestupst genannt j j j j j
j alter abbas was als ich fühle mich auf
der cra bereiten mein pferd läuft aber
sagt wird
richtiger fan alter die kuchen mit dem
fell sind einfach gemütlich ohne scheiß
so langsam sein okay das haben wir
letztes kleve tun aber da geht haben
jetzt kennt ihr den auch dann lass mal
weiter neu was ist los mit meinem leben
halt da ich will doch ich habe die die
monster kurve geschafft aber ihr seht
schon das ist ziemlich buggy auch mit
demnächst also auch ohne lecks ist das
ziemlich fragil
gerade aber 16
ich habe bei langen aufnehmen
v elf minuten schon okay allerdings
sagen sagen noch das spiel
so war das klapprad schon verzeigt bitte
bitte lass nicht sterben aufgrund von
lakers weise unehrenhaft ich will auch
leben ach man kann nie ganz verzichten
wollen abgewandert wären stünde in den e
aber das andere spiel mit den stimmen
eines ultra geil
ja auf jeden fall schaut dort an dingsda
mein party minecraft partie ist ein
geiler server nur ziemlich sieht das
nach 75 minuten spielen bezahlen muss
das ist nicht korrekt
also man hat mir den nook konnte wie ich
das verstanden habe
wenn die zeit abgelaufen ist müsst ihr
als obligatorisch bezahlen
also das ist ein bisschen meyer nicht so
geil
ach ja stimmt dass es briefe ich denke
man kann den abfall hand ich spreche den
israeli die bild dass er sich wo bleibt
eigentlich die schneewälle ich bin
gerade auf bedrock gefeierter
automatisch eliminiert
das mit startplatz da auf jeden fall her
ich bin noch drin gg alte alter altern
obwohl alter ich komme ich klar komme
ich klar okay jetzt macht ist hier ist
gar nicht was noch zu dem zeitpunkt war
nicht lange ich bin ein schwarzer mit
einem basecap
damals da facto lag ich nein nein
auf jeden fall du musst noch zählen sie
können überleben da hast du automatisch
gewonnen
ja geil das pack ich auf jeden fall also
wenn jetzt zu stellen dann fresse ich
einen besen gewonnen
dann fressen micro erster platz okay gut
wir verabschieden uns mit dem ersten
platz
ich berate fallen wenn es euch gefallen
hat lassen kommentar da lassen like da
schaut bei der cherokees vorbei so heißt
ein channel und in diesem sinne macht
gut und holte tor